ladies and gentlemen Daniel [ __ ] hey
they've let you over the border and
Scotland into England I know well I mean
it's New Castle really England I'm not
sure because like my sport Acton best
friend over the years Erica Clara's he's
from n Newcastle and it's just there's
always there's a genuine affiliation
between the majorities in the Scots
where was just like kind of yeah I mean
you're all you're pretty much just
because we're you here the South as much
as we do absolutely yeah yeah anything
that's below Leeds is southern yeah yeah
exactly yeah agreed
what's super interesting when I speak to
Americans they don't know that there is
an actual wall between Scotland and
England it's like they don't know that
Hadrian's Wall is a thing yeah like you
watch Game of Thrones right yeah yeah
you know the wall like that actually
exists it's a bit smaller and it's kind
of ruins yeah but it's actually there no
way man - and the yeah that's my walls
well Manny knows his background so when
I sometimes have to do my research for
guests yeah I interview a guy who
understands the foremost intellect on
alien civilizations have to sink my
teeth into this though the research for
yourself was watching your Netflix
specials right for watching on YouTube
and sliding in here mum's DMS I that is
my mother - a [ __ ] team I love the
woman so much I love her dearly but
she's absolute she's she's an absolute
horror for him she loves it she loved in
fact that she's there no-one is choose
over the course of the years Jim they
had Murph a small stuff my mom will
spend a lot of money going to see as
much as she can to the fence because she
supports all comedians and even when
they tried to give her like free tickets
and stuff she refuses to because she
understands how the industry works yeah
she's an absolute [ __ ] sweetheart but
yeah she loves loves the attention
and she's poking at it when she's a very
very funny woman she is she's given me
so later on I've got a couple of a
couple of things that I need to ask you
about which is the inside information
from another several years she's so chef
that a knife in my back like the
shooters were there she is yeah she
hasn't
so your Netflix special jigsaw which
some people may have seen in some may
not I want you to you if you can to just
try and explain the concept of jigsaw or
a jigsaw for life the coronaries
basically and I I don't I hate
relationships I've just hate ninety
percent of people and relationships
because they are I don't like liars
and you when you're in it most people
and relationships that are lying to me
and they're lying to them fighting sales
I was thinking there's a certain
arrogance to people in relationships
that they've achieved something that I
don't have by you know selling for this
other person that they have a happier
life than I do I enjoy being single
right I'm one day I won't enjoy somebody
one day I'll enjoy the company of the
person and I want to spend the rest of
my life with them and I believe that why
get annoyed at is by people when they
forced something into their life the
force of person into life because they
think they should be in a relationship
which is what ninety percent of you
[ __ ] do you crime this horrible
person into your life and you post
pictures about how happy you are and
you're not happy I mean no you're not
happy because you are bragging about
whenever I'm happy I'm proud about
something I'm not on Twitter going god
yeah I just nailed it on the best of
this [ __ ] I'm enjoying the thing
you're its reveling in the experience
it's I'm not boasting I'm not posting
pictures of how much fun I'm having
about the things I'm enjoying myself for
me you post about things when they're
not been well too because you'd like to
social media so you can convince
yourself so when you look back in your
pictures artificially inseminating a
sense of purpose yes and I just fear for
me somebody who's confident enough being
single you know it's it's fine but I
even I sometimes feel the pressure of
people you know people in relationships
are going oh god maybe I should be in a
relationship maybe I should settle for
that and I'm barely able to resist it so
when you're putting out this content
that's sort of bragging about how happy
you are when you're not and you are
adding to this idea that being alone is
wrong you're gonna cause people who are
of less sort of people maybe been lonely
longer than I've ever done
you know a good social circle whatever
the ELA or you know mental health issues
kind of other things they see you happy
and you've said that you weren't happy
when you're a singer and the happiness
that you got is from finding this
[ __ ] person and you're full of [ __ ]
and I think it's very very damaging and
if you want to brag about half you are
in a relationship I will absolutely brag
about happy I am being single and I will
win fantastic I am to end up in a
happiness competition and a bragging
competition I'll [ __ ] bar let's let's
get our dicks out and measure them you
know exactly so I mean I am firmly in
the same camp as yourself and I think
there is a it's a very nuanced
understanding of relationships to be
able to say that I am happy unhappy on
my own because it sounds an awful lot
like you don't want someone mmm which
isn't the case normally I think from
watching a special it sounds like an
uncompromising set standard on what you
will accept as a partner i it's not even
that like I don't think getting a
partner they should sort of be anything
I don't have any expectations of my
future partner for me I just think
falling in love should be the most
inconvenient thing in the [ __ ] world
like it should ruin your day like people
who when they fall in love like I know
it's in love because every time I
thought about them I smiled and I was
happy I'm like no no that's you in love
with the idea of love it's not by the
individual you didn't love with the idea
of being in love and you love the
feeling of being loved when you're
nicely in love like I think it's just
you know you just go off for [ __ ] sake
I was having so much fun I was living my
best life and then this person came
along and they make me laugh and I want
to spend my time with him I love used to
love being alone I know every time I'm
in a situation I'm enjoying my brain
goes I wish this person was here with me
I want to share this with the [ __ ] god
that having so much fun yeah I had so
much freedom and I still have that but
just now I can't stop it oh yeah every
time I've been in love I've just gone
you bet yeah I love you so much and
that's so inconvenient for me because I
was enjoying being selfish I was
enjoying and now I love you so much
that you're my priority and that's
insanity I suppose I suppose what
application there is the if you if a
major part of your life and your purpose
worth happiness is derived from your
relationship with someone else it puts a
lot of power in someone else's hands
right like you don't look like you need
to feel very vulnerable at the mercy and
at the behest of what they want to do to
you
yeah I think I think you should you know
the person you're with should make you
so happy like all the time like if they
make you feel bad you know then get rid
of them I've never understood that I
find the concept for the one is the most
arrogant thing in the entire and this is
coming from an incredibly out of good
man but the concept of the of the one is
so narcissistic that not even I can fall
into youth you're telling me if you
believe in the one there's only one
person on this planet that's good enough
for you whine to your [ __ ] man
one-mile radius I can find you a hundred
people who are do you'd say yesterday
yeah yeah who are not only good enough
for me but bear yeah just yeah I am but
we we create this idea and oh my god
when it gets difficult put the work in
why if it's not easy like I think you
know every and I've done those
relationships you know I've been in
those relationships with you the person
makes you feel like [ __ ] and you know
you look at your pension you look at our
grandparents generation because none of
them would get divorced because it was
too inconvenient and [ __ ] being alone
was so taboo and it was you know with
the only way you're ever out of a
relationship as if one of them [ __ ]
died you know back when all of our
granddad's were perverts and they were
perverts they were stalkers how did you
meet your gran oh well she didn't want
me at first and then I [ __ ] water
diver [ __ ] Jesus that's awful that's
horrendous
you just lived in a time when you were
just able to stand outside work with
flowers will I gonna love you and she
worthy and she didn't have the internet
or a phone or tinder to know that there
were options I've cited the five miles
that she inhabited yeah all right we are
grandparents live through their [ __ ]
tastes and they just made in the city
and some of them did stay together for
love but I just think they come out of
[ __ ] World War two I think five years
old and there was just a week after were
alive
that makes them more of a let's make
loads yeah exactly something I think
people are quite quick to judge the I
guess the Gen Y and the and the
Millennials for this very transactional
nature of relationships and it's easy
come easy go and a lot of the time you
hear people talk wistfully about this
like all the time why people would you
know they'd stick it out and this and
the other but I mean
sticking it out in a relationship sounds
an awful lot like an incompatibility to
me yeah ii know just been like you know
while you know we've been together for
this sunken cost fallacy like it's
exactly there you go up i spent on this
time ago and i and i get those feelings
i've been in those relationships you go
I've put three years into it like am I
willing to a say in the show I mean you
got that choice
you give willing to either admit the
last three years of your life had been a
waste or am I going to waste the rest of
my life and it's a tough [ __ ] thing
and also breakup breakups always suck as
well like even if it's mutual sometimes
the mutual ones are the saddest ones
yeah they are wait both of you know yeah
neither of you are happy yeah but but
you don't hate each other you just broke
you grow apart like my first girlfriend
when we first for two and a half years
and we broke up usually she didn't cry I
sobbed for the hope because I felt so
guilty I was like god I'm destroying her
life as she was like no decade like I'll
be fine with that yeah like I wouldn't
miss you and but we you know she was
like look we have grown apart there's
nothing wrong with it like we don't hate
each other there's no anymore so we
didn't cheer each other we weren't just
[ __ ] at points you just win and
that's not it's not you and that's
really those are sad cuz that's like you
know so much easier if the persons I
can't hear they've cheated on you
because it's very very sharp line to
throw and you score it's done it's over
done Dave's been ripped but when you
know when you if you don't grow together
you know when you grow in different
directions there's always that Ben's
like oh god this is me well you know cuz
you're never gonna blame them I mean I
think one of the things I noticed when I
was especially young was that I felt
like there was a the world was ours to
be girdled around the relationship and
not that we were being stretched by the
world and it's like no man like just
Louisville Louisville when like level oh
it does
mother likes I had a girlfriend there
was a dancer and a B thir and then she's
gonna go dancing in Egypt when she came
back from B thir and this I knew that I
was like man it was a holiday romance
yeah they like concede the fact that it
was a holiday romance but no no I was
gonna try and launch a business do a
master's in international marketing at
Newcastle University and have a
relationship with the dancer who was in
Egypt at the same time see oh I like
looking back like what the [ __ ] were you
doing like every night that would be me
I'd be concerned she'd be out dancing
till late is she drinking is the [ __ ]
Steve Angelo and his [ __ ] you know is
he around and is he's impossible abla I
think just just like she's not happy
because you're complaining and you're
insecure all the time yeah and you're
forcing your insecurities onto how you
been I get that I'll think about what
you do whatever all what if I can do but
why do you trust me enough to know that
I'm not going to intentionally be a bad
person towards you yeah it says more
about yourself in your impression of me
yeah so yeah I think that's that's one
of the things that really struck me and
one of the other things that I really
liked was how you talked about the
innate desire for people to feel like
they need to have someone to make
themselves whole and I think that that
is part of the jigsaw analogy itself
right that you have particular quadrants
of the jigsaw that you put together yeah
could you explain those yeah well so
originally it was the idea was like
you've got obviously with the judge so
you start on the outside you've got the
four corners you know and this is
obviously different for different people
but in the analogy I use it was like
friends family job and hobbies like and
those are transferrable they're
different from you and somewhere you
know your family my family's very
important to me so my friends and I'm
first I love my job
don't have many hobbies isn't that
Corner's obviously small for me but for
other people you know maybe they [ __ ]
hate their family maybe their family is
[ __ ] and maybe leave only like three
close friends but they've got lots of
hobbies and that their job is an officer
of consuming thing and it's you know the
problem of the jigsaw analogy is people
just don't change over the years they're
always the same picture what is you
changed those points we just go [ __ ] I
don't wanna be obsessed my job anymore
or you know
in my fault I want my family but to be
bigger now and yet after sort of a movie
right
so is it constantly changing in their
shifting thing for the one thing we all
want and is we all feel broken if we
don't have someone there the reason we
feel broken is because of how we raise
children you know the TV shows
everything is about love everything is
about relationships you know our parents
divorce is very very common it's a very
very common thing and there's nothing
wrong with it but divorce that this is
talking about for some folks kids is
very sort of taboo because you can't
tell kids that sometimes love is wrong
you can tell an eight-year-old that
they're gonna get it wrong so many
[ __ ] Highness have so many times
before they get it right because that's
not what you want the story of you know
love to be when you you're seven or
eight years old and I think maybe right
yeah you know it's always the Disney
princess gets the Prince of the Prince
gets the princess or it's always about
these relationships the whole focus of
ever every single TV shows and I've done
is even now when I'm pitching TV shows
they go who's the love interest you're
like well I doesn't have to be a [ __ ]
love interest like why does my show that
has nothing to do with love what is my
calculator why is that important they
you're his or her growth like it's
people just need to know a lot of people
feel the desire to latch on to that
particular story then right it's a story
of hope and redemption for people who
don't have it and I guess a hope of
continuation for those who do mmm yeah
then again I've always said that I've
got nothing against relationships and
Jake's always never meant to be a
breakup show and it's not it's a love
letter to single people
I just took me so long to be secure with
being single they took me to know you
know especially family stuff when you
get mine from having kids you like
whenever I [ __ ] want yeah and if I
don't have them tough [ __ ] like get a
grandchild from your other kids I don't
care I've adorned all yes and I was I
was it my business partners wedding a
few years ago him and his missus
being together since they were 20 they
are the exact opposite the polar
opposite of my situation just about to
have their second child and they've got
two dogs and it is like the white picket
fence the British white mounds
equivalent I wrote is wedding and we've
been there for the weekend it's been
beautiful and everything's amazing and
the families got on and the service is
fantastic and this that any other as I'm
driving away I can see his mum and a
couple of her family members just
looking at me as I drove past and I
could just see in their eyes they were
thinking you're next
and I've won the window down as I won't
be soon there are there are different
paths in love life for different people
mm-hmm like in it yeah ie so some of us
don't get me wrong I'm an absolute
romantic like I want to I want to be a
dad more than anything in the world I
really really do and I want to get mine
don't want to have kids I want that I
just don't think I have to do it before
I'm 30 and I don't think I think I'm not
looking for it at all like I'm
thoroughly enjoying you know because I'm
not being in a relationship and not
being it that means I can be selfish as
[ __ ] at the moment I can travel as much
as I travel for my job I can really
focus on and one day that will change
one day some god damn woman is going to
come in my life and just be perfect and
I'm going to you I didn't realize that I
was writing all of these routines and it
was yeah the [ __ ] hypocrisy Oh see
what I get into a [ __ ] relationship
my fines are gonna be like you [ __ ]
what like I know I'm sorry she made me I
didn't mean to lay my heart look at her
with our [ __ ] perfect little laugh
like for some reason makes me feel warm
and say all that yeah I would be a
hypocrite I'm gonna be an absolute
advocate but no but I also won't be
because I never cancer elationship so
I'm against fake relationships and the
more fake relationships that exist you
are it's it's it's a disease like you
see you'll say they go I'm so happy I'm
so happy in this relationship and you're
not but you'll lie to your friends that
are single and go I'm so happy with
Jonathan or I'm so happy with Claire and
they'll go [ __ ] how they
they hate each other they get through it
yeah that's what we must must do and you
say you just go [ __ ] ID this person
I'll change who I am you know everyone
says it takes work why why does that
have to take work like if you've got
kids absolutely like if it's but when
you're just starting I don't like well
if I had to know this might sound insane
and that's because I have if I if if I'm
in a relationship and we have one
argument in that first year bye yeah
like it oh we have disagreements like
yeah I love he won't find a plum Pete's
are the hope out of love it yeah yeah we
could do that but like if like let's see
I can fundamentally yeah like you I have
a lot of female friends one of my best
friends in the world is caught up in
France with Jean for eight years we left
together she's one of my closest friends
if I was ever in a relationship with
someone who's like you need to see Jean
Lance I would be like you can absolutely
take a running fight to yourself like
it's you know that because that's you
that's that's see the jealousy which
I've don't suffer from so it's maybe you
know I have any um have any [ __ ]
sympathy for it yeah because it's those
are your insecurities and I and trust me
I will do everything through you know
found with someone I don't want them to
feel insecure you know I think your job
is to make that person you know feel
loved and value bullying but you know
even if you do that and they're still
[ __ ] jealous you're like I can't you
know it's not my job but I didn't fight
the [ __ ] idea yeah yeah it's not your
job to fix me and it's not my job to fix
you you know I don't know you don't owe
anyone anything
yep really when you spend a lot of time
together you've been in a relationship
aware of you sometimes you feel you how
do you how do you think we mediate then
between someone who thinks this
relationship might not be right me and
Daniel said like you know too many
disagreements and too many complaints
and too much upset is a bad idea and
then aside where you may find some form
of a blockage within a relationship
which requires some work to be done
which you then push through to find a
newer level obviously the Devils in the
details there yeah I mean that's you
know there's a problem with one of the
many problems with the the jigsaw
analogy of my show which is yeah nothing
is black and white and while I'm up
there doing is I'm saying this is the
black and this is the white because
there
new ones sometime I would need to
discuss it Michael it would be seven
even a day we need volumes yeah but
there are psychologists who say for
years who don't even are able to you
know explain to that level of sort of
detail it's up to you if it feels you
know right I totally believe that there
are some relationships should require
work like if you're feeling a little bit
you should have dumped someone out of
the blue necessarily you should go
here's what I feel like I'm either less
attracted to you or or I miss the spark
that we used to have or a thing or what
I feel like I'm changing in this way and
your push minute with you talk to the
person open the communication before you
break up and then if they're like well
that's not going to change then it's
different for everyone it is nuts that's
where the devil being in the details
it's obviously where the wide
relationships are hard like and it's not
harder than it has to be hard work as in
sometimes it's just going to take a lot
of cognitive power but one of the things
that you touch on that I really really
like is that you need to love yourself
before you can learn to love someone
else and before you can allow them to
love you yeah and I I think you need to
be able to understand your own values
and what you will and will not tolerate
within yourself mm-hmm like there's
certain things that I've realized are
Keystone habits and Keystone failures of
myself and when I get them right I feel
ten times better and when I get the
wrong I feel ten times worse but I never
knew that I was being triggered on those
by partners and I was projecting onto
partners for a decade yeah until I
actually did a bit of introspective work
and then realize that yeah holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] like the problem was never with
that the problem was with them but it
was other things yes but you knows you
didn't especially come out of
relationship is where we come out over
teenage years none of us are [ __ ]
confident right even the confident
teenagers like deep down weren't
oh yeah confident like we're all we're
all just [ __ ] balls of hormones
hormones here and it occurs in anxiety
you know we're just filled up to her
balls with common we were horny and we
didn't know why and we didn't know what
to do and you said there you get to see
you're insecure and you you know they
suddenly go you're an adult especially
your teenager they were gonna a young
adult you got a [ __ ] teenager Armagh
young I'm a child I'm a child I'm 28 and
now I'm a young adult yeah I'm a young
adult only now is before that I was a
[ __ ] I was a child i how dare you
could have like I understood what I was
[ __ ] say so it's like over yogurt all
full of [ __ ] no I was not and the fact
that you even let me believe I was a
young adult is ridiculous if you know
anything [ __ ] child abuse yeah and
then you get into it so you don't love
yourself cause you don't know who you
are and the problem is when you get to a
relationship that is special when we go
into university I mean not like dead by
soft monks my friends is you go through
the same to really like - you're going
to change so much because you know you
don't really choose what [ __ ] high
school you go to or who your friends you
pick a friend of this randomly selected
of people in your [ __ ] area who
happened to be born in the same year
like none of them are these just friends
with them out of convenience never do it
you'll get friends for life and whatnot
but when you go to university there's a
lot more freedom to it you're gonna grow
naturally in university just after high
school we're going to change so much and
I feel like sometimes if you're in a
relationship there which you would be
like oh god here's this scaly new world
that I'm a [ __ ] and dull and what do
adults do or adults or man it adults
through relationships what I'll do to be
an adult or get into a [ __ ]
relationship and I'll doing salad for my
appearance state which is compromising
change and do anything to make this
relationship work because that's what
adults do and you sit there and you
create this false version for yourself
and it's not malicious in any way that
the person that you know they're not
changing you for bad reasons you're like
please change me I want to do anything I
love you and you make me happy and I
want to make you as happy as you make me
so I will change or willingly change for
you and then seven years later you're
like I don't even [ __ ] like rock
climbing [ __ ] hate cheese and wine
like why I watched Eat Pray Love 75 and
it's really hard because that person
that changed you they
necessarily for sure I'm gonna make this
kind of rock climbing oh yeah you just
decide yourself I'll do whatever makes
you happy and you know just hope
something like hey I like football
just like being it's like being moldable
putty right and and you're just so
malleable at that early age I mean I
okay that's confusing man when it is
loves you do Anna's brother a person you
would and one of the maddest things and
the crazy duality that we need to hold
in both both of these need to exist
together right so you need to say you
are crazy malleable you are going to be
potentially changed in a manner that is
inappropriate and damaging to you but
you also kind of need to experience
these things and you also need to suffer
so you can learn yeah so you can't
expedite the success and avoid the
suffering but also if you could get it
absolutely right you could I mean that
off [ __ ] hell mate you wanna have
your cake and eat it and throw out the
window as well like I just think we the
best some of the best lessons I learned
about myself I learned from failed
relationship hundred seven hundred which
is why Jamie like you know you know I
like the fact that I'm friends with them
you know a loved one or we're not
friends with my exes but we ended on
sort of harm a couple times and I've got
no sort of ill feelings towards him even
the person that jigsaw was about you
know sort of managed to and that should
writing that [ __ ] was very cathartic I
was gonna say I mean surely once that
got published the I listening question I
don't know if she has washed it and but
you know I think she'll you know letter
bombs or anything yet no nobody I think
they think she'd understand as well it's
I mean it's very respectful I think
personally like if I I do say she's the
worst person I've ever met
okay yeah I mean well yeah but there's
got to be some comedic kind of yeah a
bit of artistic license yeah yeah and
also excited Rachel yeah
it wasn't it was it was a terrible
terrible relationship and it took a
while to recover from because that's
always think it's well like whenever you
get it wrong you feel like such a dick
yeah is it those are the world well I
think one of the worst feelings in the
world and a relationship is you know
when this is such a shame that the line
it's not you as me is it's cliche and if
you ever say that the person you're
breaking up will hate you because
sometimes is that it's the only honest
thing it's the break o equivalent
electrics and chill and I'm like no
that's what I want to do I really do
want to watch some Netflix and chill
alright festival documentaries heritable
yeah and sometimes it is not you it's me
you've done nothing wrong
I'm just changing and it my future
doesn't involve you and you feel so [ __ ]
because this person that you know loved
you unconditionally and sort of you know
was them is amazing there's nothing
wrong with them and you don't love them
you feel so proud you feel evil you are
you an empathetic individual Agito
hugely I hate my I hate my levels of
empathy one of my biggest weaknesses and
I've only just recently begun to realize
it yeah I I really and I do I think
let's not criticize empathy I think the
whole world could do with a lot more of
it but we've got can we take some of
mine oh my [ __ ] god I can't handle it
which is why I fill up so many a lot
walls sometimes it was just like if
people knew how empathetic it was they
take advantage of me they're obsessed so
that's why I just you know that's why I
make sure that my hope for my whole
provider when stage is on belly Big
bollocks nothing you can say will ever
make me question anything otherwise I'm
so weird in all of my opinions I'm the
smartest man alive I'm God that's what
my whole persona is that it's just
because you know if you knew her you
know it's so much easier to come across
as cold and I don't give a [ __ ] I think
so and I do think as well that the
empathy thing means that when when the
iron gets struck really really well like
it the the world can come crashing down
pretty quick and I think like weird
stuff for me like you what level of okay
like if you see someone cry do you
immediately start willing and I say it's
difficult I I mean
like to the point where if I if if I
ever hear if I ever hear like a little
wise but if I ever hear like a a like a
girl like a small girl just shout for
her dad for summary there we go I'm not
even a dad if I'm like wait I'm talking
about girls have called me daddy before
about a very different ones they were
much older but why do I just hear the I
don't know what isn't here and I what I
do some [ __ ] weird [ __ ] searches for
so long as well like I stop myself from
crying and my teenagers and I've got no
idea why is it okay my father is my
death my I've seen my dad cry before
like my dad was never one of those guys
that's like he's like crying wait he's
never said they ever I've seen my dad
cry
he was logical yeah and he would be
always always in control of his emotions
but if the man wanted to cry he'd
[ __ ] cry for some reason I thought
when I got it from I got this idea in my
head that crying was weak and I would
physically stop myself from crying at
movies and stuff like you do we better
be like no yeah nah ah great UT yes I'm
alone and I'm stalking myself and crying
like a [ __ ] sociopath
yeah because I hate my empathy I hate if
I went pathetic it was whit is now I
fully embrace her I just told you to
don't do YouTube holes of stuff that no
this is gonna make me cry you see
they're dehydrated from tell us yeah
once way down again if I feel that like
I haven't been emotional enough one
month I'll just get bottle white and
I'll sit down on [ __ ] YouTube and
I'll watch as soldiers coming home to
their dogs
that's some serious yeah that gets me a
deaf babies being given hearing aids
yeah sobbing yeah openly sobbing yeah
and they're using the chroma it crumbs
the colorblind glasses yeah yeah I was
for the first time we did my new one is
and this is my is adoptive dad's would
like that like be like the kids taking
their second name oh yeah yeah yeah like
you guys miss your being like yeah oh
yeah no no no it's always that it's it's
the doors are the sons to there stabbed
I've been like I've made
so you see these beg grown man that are
like six foot five look like they used
to be a prison heavily tattooed and this
like this 30 year old girl is you my dad
no and Ebro just comes crushing oh man
it destroys me I love it so links to
everything will be in the show notes
below if you want to have a nice cry at
some point o do it it's like I was I do
too for so many years I repress it so
much of like not okay
it's like bleeding the radio you like
your [ __ ] baby pithy junk you know
yeah Omar's just like skydiving just be
like one [ __ ] click give me another
line of dogs meeting their own eyes yeah
I've never been on a plane and not watch
the blanks and soaped matters any
international flight I'm like a [ __ ]
blindsides on this um I'm sad for blood
but I'm a very upper what upper class
wealthy woman I want to adopt a black
child to play megam football which is
support I have no interested I love it
but I get I love Carly I think you know
there may be some people out there who
can empathize with our empathy and
whatnot they're weak oh yeah must suck
to be there but yeah I know one of the
problems that occurs off the back of
that is being able to break up with
someone you lead it to earlier on way
you said that you were terrified that
you were just gonna end somebody's world
mm-hmm
and the understanding the reality that
other people will be fine they're gonna
be okay they'll be sad and that's
because breakups are always sad yeah
they just uh even if it's a bad
relationship that person was part of
your life and they would a big big part
of your life and they're not and you're
losing when you lose really breakups are
you losing a part of yourself there you
know it's just always gonna be sad like
even if you boomers on with the [ __ ]
three months or a great three months or
there were but you spent so much time
think about it's the closing of a
chapter and is that there's a recency
bias as well right that it's difficult
to remember what life was like before
somewhere you can be with someone third
you know three to six months mm-hmm and
you like especially if you you special
if you're in a sort of 34 years old like
that's a significant proportion of your
life and it's the most recent yeah
proportion of you a portion of your life
so you like [ __ ] out like yeah of
course this person feels like a very
very large part what did i do want to
Sunday morning before we did realized
Sunday's over 90 next yeah like I've you
know I you know they made me love olives
and now I love olives no can I ever have
an olive again without thinking of him
look over at the [ __ ] olives yeah but
it doesn't feel like that at the time
also I understand like a people who are
they you know when you're in one of
those relationships and you know that
you're gonna break up with the person it
just becomes you know you're negotiating
with terrorists but the terrorist is
yourself you're gonna do it next week
alright you know so he's a thing you
like can't dump them before Christmas
because they probably Amish Christmas
presents and let's or about don't let's
go film the family and they I can't
break up with them in new year but yes
it can be new year and then I can't do
it before Valentine's Day cos
Valentine's Day is coming up and you
just I'm very much of the stance and
it's very hard to do but I have done it
in my past couple of relationships is
that I go the second I know I'm breaking
out with them I do it that day that
would be a fantastic rule to live by I
Thanks tough as hell it is difficult but
I do think that these sort of these
heuristics and the frameworks listeners
who have listened to relationships 101
102 and 103 if you haven't listened to
them you need to go listen to them now
yeah we try and come up with these these
guidelines because in the analogy that I
use is you know that you're gonna fall
into some quicksand and you know it's
gonna happen in a week's time
Iraqi I'm gonna I mean research online
I'm gonna look at the techniques for
getting out of quicksand and then when
it happens I'll be prepared and I'll
have my stick with me and I'll do the
dis and then in a second iteration of
this world I push you in some quicksand
and I go right get your phone out have a
look out [ __ ] ghetto quicksand to be
like without a plan in advance and
without some rules and heuristics to
stick to this situation moves your
capacity to perceive what's happening
efficiently and effectively so far that
you don't you your ability to make
choices is effectively muted mmm any
like rule okay so these kind of rules
like that actually a really good way of
bringing people back down to earth and I
have made
relationships that I know I'm going to
break up with the person in that period
has lasted longer than the bit before it
in the past and I mean that is a it's
also cruel like that's it's one of the
things that the and if anyone's that
there is in a relationship that you'd
know you're about to get out of the one
thing that always inspired me was always
the second you know it's over with that
person every minute that you spend with
them is cruel because you are wasting
their time you know there's no future in
it they don't know that and and and they
need the time to to grieve to for the
break-up and stuff and the time to move
on and your every minute the year with
them is you were stealing a moment off
their recovery in the future off of them
and that is the most selfish because the
other thing I was a so selfish for me to
break up with this person where is no no
the opposite is true it's so selfish to
not like yeah they're gonna they're
gonna be heartbroken you're gonna be
[ __ ] on are broken and you're gonna be
filled with [ __ ] doubts but if you
love them as much as you claim to and
even if it's not in that way you [ __ ]
dumped him stop stringing them along
stop wasting their time stop when
they're [ __ ] sperm shrivel up in their
balls or the right shrivel up in their
poly or whatever if I can think you know
you are right I mean externalizing that
accountability to someone else's is a
real surefire way of driving home just
how much time you wasted you're not
wasting you you're just wasting your own
but you're wasting their wasting there's
like if you if you know you said they're
the reason you don't wanna break up with
that person is because you don't want
the heart won right and that is
admirable like that's really there is a
really really nice thing you you're
willing to sacrifice your life to make
this person happy but that's also
[ __ ] cruel like you're gonna rob this
person of the chance of true love like
that's what you're gonna do you're gonna
stay with them and pretend to love them
to save their [ __ ] heartbreak you're
not that's not a nice thing you're doing
like you're just you're putting them in
the [ __ ] Truman Show yep like that's
what you're doing is like everything's
fine everybody's died and they're like
well he's smiling so [ __ ] me like he is
say he doesn't look make as much eye
contact and walked on the four plays a
bit late but he says he loves me look at
the ring well it's it is very very true
I wish that it didn't strike such a it
didn't resonate so hard with me but it
does and you know I very well may do to
a lot of people at home I want to move
on to the next most important topic on
my list which is how important it is to
have a shaved [ __ ]
you are among friends here this is a
safe space and everyone who is listening
will know just how much we appreciate a
clean is just for sharing a [ __ ]
weight dual purpose is super person
ranging army and so have you tried to
shut off a bday so it's the Arabic bday
that's kind of on a hose if you've ever
been to Asian and Arab countries I have
ever used it so I'm just I'm screwed
about where the war goes so that's the
thing so the issue that you have when
you come up against one of these be days
especially one that's in Yousef one of
the co-hosts house like the pressure
that comes out of it is enough to clean
dirt off a car and if you're not holding
sufficient if you get the angle wrong it
comes out your mouth
what's an enema your enemy yourself
because you don't have enough anal tone
and yeah it's up but give us the if
someone's debating if they thought I you
know considered shave my ass but I don't
really understand why why should someone
show through well first of all we belong
to the older generation stiff collars
the millennial generation where every
generation my generation is the
a-sitting generation like I Jamie I
would love to see the statistics of how
many people poor in Iraq now you know
you may lick each other's heart cuz it's
a it's most of us yeah and it's
definitely more than previous
generations or at least or or or my gran
is very very private about her roaming
schedule yeah but I I originally do just
because I might I don't have much
[ __ ] body hair it's not who I am but
for some reason it is all call letters
on my arse and white pins a nightmare
like [ __ ] my door down there look at
the [ __ ] crack maggots you know when
you're wiping them it's over I and I was
just like it's just one point you
scratch at something it's that talk it
scrubs is horrible yeah I don't be wrong
shaving your [ __ ] is not a graceful
process there's no good there's no good
way to do it what's your technique
the shame squat she's a squat in the in
the bath
chainsaw in this era like holding razors
at the heads just because it's really a
life-and-death situation every time the
the you know I mean I I need to talk
about the you do is well I sometimes
need to work myself up to it
oh I know that when I know that like are
so shaving days coming in yeah I yeah
you bell W go for the show ease to
yourself night maybe like some candles
yeah yeah we're gonna go for it it's
it's got but I'm also the thing like it
look if I want somebody to stick their
[ __ ] tongue in my butt I'm gonna give
them the best but to do that exactly
it's gonna make sure it's clean like
it's the same thing you know when it
comes to sort of pubic in general I
don't give a [ __ ] where you have you
don't I don't give a [ __ ] we have body
here in your politic like regardless of
your gender it's [ __ ] your body your
choice but just be a decent human being
grew like it like if you're sitting
there you like imma you're like yeah if
you just I've never sucked I've never
sucked a dick so for the purposes
analogy I'm gonna be talking about
[ __ ] just because I have more
experience in that right you can change
the gender for whichever one takes your
fancy right but you can be like hey I'm
a woman and a we get here to those
places and I'm not gonna shave my legs
and I'm not gonna shave my pits and I'm
like cool I'm not liking your legs
through your armpits yeah I'm looking
your [ __ ] right you know and if you
have hair up there absolutely but just
you know in the same way that I've
shaved my balls
I don't shave my pubes but you know make
sure this is my balls going on your
mouth yeah I'm [ __ ] hating your mouth
that's weird
unless you like that which gives fair
play to you but let me know and I'll
stop shaving them but man shaving your
ass what matters game change of what is
so much easier you know it's the the
sheer difference in toilet paper usage
and time yeah it's so much it compare
for the environment it's Jordan know
what the equivalent is that we found for
shaving yourself for shoes shoehorn man
anyone who's not using a shoe on now I
implore you if you're a fan of this
channel you will know exactly one
because a man is there just a life like
that none of us know
oh my everybody should know few things
that everybody should do drive an
automatic car turn these are disagree a
mood
Daniel come on he was going so well okay
you know I just saw this leg and this
arm they can just this entire life are
you tired what roughly yes now I just
want to maximize like a flamingo driving
I have a stroke nothing on the lenses
work every stroke on your right side
well I guess I'm well you know what I
know I'm wrong there's an amazing
comedian Colton make Cody who's got a be
drive to my magic card and his argument
as I have known a buffle towards it you
know it's it's 2004 it's 2019 right why
don't you go Chum your own [ __ ] butter
yeah like it's just this easier option
exists why
for me it's overtaking like every time I
just you slammed anything in the end of
car goes fifth gear and you're like
seconds you know those roads where did
you say you go over to these [ __ ]
lorries my [ __ ] that's a good castle
to see on this you mean style yeah and
when you go over like if you're if I'm
in a manual car I go right I need to be
in third gear for this thing so you cut
my throat straight right right you know
not my car you go out ladies like Jordan
be a sec you know what you say second is
like go just [ __ ] fat fast I'm going to
die would you yeah okay so we've got and
we will agree to disagree on the
automatic versus money I know you're
right it's the future and I show me you
know that you will convert you it's
legal its equivalent vinyl shut up and
drive I don't know you need a room for
your music it's one of those things
where I know I'm wrong but I'm not
changing my opinion so we've got
shoehorn we've got off my car turn the
sensitivity up on the trackpad on your
MacBook so turn it up to the highest it
will be within a week temperature more
productive immediately promise you yeah
game change
and the final one my it's you know
Johnny one of the co-hosts actually even
he moved back up vertically integrated
himself into his bowel movements and
went to develop a green smoothie on a
morning which means that he's just y+
now that his bowel movements are so
consistent and so well formed that
absolutely perfect every single time any
like well oh my god like a single sheet
Janome like it
and not even double ply if you see your
finger through yes Tillie he does that
gamble away he goes so I am going to
move on to mother sloths and what she's
given us so she's mama bear she's given
us a number of options of things that I
can ask you about and I'm gonna ask you
all of them and then you can you can
choose okay so robot wars and the
pregnant washing up story oh yeah all
the cans of deodorant story oh yeah or
rapping Shakespeare or at the age of 13
he drew his first graphic novel based on
his baby brother called my life with
Hitler my life with Satan oh I'll
happily compare but I'll happily declare
my three old brother to shame but he was
definitely not Hitler asked like its
first steps weren't [ __ ] good steps
thank you well that's it like the fact
that she thinks his mom pay attention
would you come on
it was definitely my life for the same
you um I [ __ ] hate my younger brother
man
hey him so much he's a lot of checks to
the age gap cuz my hair so when I was
eight years old my sexual sister dies
and their that's what my sure dark is
sort of about so there was a huge age
gap between so my brother was born when
I was 10 years old and yet he was born
then so these are when I was going when
I was 13 years old
he was three and [ __ ] he sucked a hair
of my so annoying
and and in the house I know it was to
everything he was doing he was just
trying to get my attend this to me all
the time they were like he's just trying
to annoy you is because it's build time
you ever pain with
he doesn't care if you're yelling out or
being mean to him you're his older
brother and he loves you and he wants
you to pay attention even was yelling
and so just be nice to him and he'll not
annoy you
now la la la la la I'm 13 I know much
[ __ ] bear I used to cheat use an evil
little [ __ ] genius man to this day my
mother doesn't believe the story I'm a
[ __ ] swear to god it's true Matthew
used to carry around a bucket full of
dummies right we've loved loved his
dummies like he called the Me's couldn't
say dummy weather you know he just
couldn't take home his meats and he did
his bucket full of Me's and he just walk
her in like a you know I knew every
minute it would change it to a Thomas
the Tank Engine 1 2 up half a pig
[ __ ] wire you'd have this bucket full
of Me's one day I'm sat down and
watching TV and he walks into the room
just his [ __ ] back fat taller toddler
Bay barely hanging out if he's two and a
half at this point we've seized me and
Mike here we [ __ ] go Mike and like
he's gonna do something to annoy me I'm
gonna push him over because I'm a
horrible bit it comes up to me takes it
takes his dummy out his mouth and he
hands it to me and I'm you know my mom
and dad always been like could you be
nicer to your brother I was like okay
that's something nice and a positively
reinforce this behavior she gave me the
dummy was like thank you very much
Matthew that's very very kind of me and
I go back to Washington he stands there
for like two minutes just calculating I
and I know you'd be like two-year-old
can calculate you [ __ ] calculating
math so all that God's just thinking
thinking and they gave me the full
bucket of all the other dummies and I
was like Thank You Matthew this is very
very kind of me and then he took in a
huge inhale a breath and screamed the
[ __ ] house down comes into me holding
his dummy and his buckets a tummy while
he's [ __ ] crying right and she's like
why did you do I'm like all right he
gave them to me she's like why is he
crying that and I'm like you [ __ ] and
she still visibly that I swear to god
that is true he's a hot I love him no I
mean I loved him then but yeah yeah
labor of love yeah yeah that was my that
was yet so ever talk about in comics
Monica was I was terrible at drawing I
just I like doing anything to make my
parents laugh when I was young mm-hmm
what's the pregnant washing machine oh
the
the pregnant washing up story so when my
mother was pregnant with I think it was
Jack it was either jack or Matthew this
is my father's third or fourth chocolate
was born so my mom's eight months
pregnant and she says a [ __ ] snap but
that's that's not maliciously lazy he's
just sometimes forgetful or just a bit
like he works all day and he comes when
we didn't want to necessarily you know
do something but he's gonna like to
style because my mom works all day and
still does chores around the [ __ ]
house so she's in the right and she's
also pregnant at this point in her life
so she circles tumorigenesis I can you
just be a bit more useful I know you you
know just be a bit I'm [ __ ] pregnant
there's some stuff I physically can no
longer do anymore
like I thought like eight months
pregnant is like yeah you like a globe
exactly it's totally spherical yeah and
she's like I can't do the dishes anymore
like physically like because often
there's a [ __ ] you [ __ ] baby and she
goes could you just make my life a
little bit easier and that night while
she sleep my dad welded a semicircle
into the think selicia case oh my god
which is yeah Wow I mean a level of
happiness I aspire to unbelievable oh
yeah I'm actually a radio ad impress ya
know she gave she [ __ ] beautiful
flavor she absolutely chenda me Daniel
I've absolutely loved today thank you
very much fun thing about my own um
can you tell the listeners where they
can find you online and what shows you
gonna be doing why are you gonna be soon
so you can I would cross the border I
would just recommend going on to Netflix
I've got too many specials on there
they're called parents lost live shows
first ones called dark the second one's
called chick so if you enjoy those
specials or I'm on tour literally
everywhere in the world to entertain
lost comm and if you don't enjoy the
specials
cool don't let me know I don't need to
know no I don't need to know I have no
interest in you've you've heavy crap
just move on forget me I'll forget you
peace enough man thank you very much for
your time that's my wants to choose
[Music]
you